What's it like?
Always knowing the truth.
There's nothing mystical about it. I can just tell.
When anyone is lying?
Yeah.
I know what you
did here psycho.
You're gonna find
Charlie Cale
and you're gonna
bring her to me.
You live on the road, right?
What's it like, to leave
everything behind,
start fresh?
I've got wolves on my fender.
I gotta keep moving.
Holy. Holy.
It wasn’t an accident. I- I think there’s been a murder.
Look out!
I have been kind of
a death magnet.
Ahh!
I’m trying to figure
out what happened.
You watch too
much Dateline.
I could tell she was lying.
So what is this, a
woman’s intuition?
No, it’s not like a tampon
commercial, okay?
It’s a real thing.
You’re coming with me.
Front seat or the trunk.
Your choice.
I guess I’m not over
the part where
you’re a human lie detector.
Yeah, I know. It’s
uh- it’s crazy.
You ever gamble? Cause
you could make a killing.
Nah.